what's up guys Justine here today we're
going to be unboxing the Mac Pro I
posted a video asking you guys if you
thought that I should keep this or not
because I was concerned that Apple is
going to come out with basically
massively upgraded version of this very
very soon which is still very possible
but it gets upgrades so I think for the
time being I'm going to keep this
because the current computer that I have
is pretty much
unfortunately unusable the hard drives
have crashed two times it's one of the
IMAX that came out I think it like 2012
it also had a hard drive crash that was
connected to it so one of my external
drives also crashed because of I don't
even know what happened but note self in
to all of you always back up your files
did I back up my files no so the
questions that I asked you was do you
think I should keep the Mac Pro most of
you said yes keep it but return the
display it's only a thunderbolt display
and it's not 4k so there's a ton of
other options out there which I have not
currently looked into so I really don't
know of any good 4k screens that I have
done zero research if you guys have any
suggestions leave me some comments below
and I will check those out think I'm
gonna open up the Thunderbolt Display
cuz I can still return it if I don't
like it but I do think that I'm going to
want a higher resolution screen
especially doing video everything else
that comes with basically running a
studio I am a one-person studio hello
I'm here we've got a camera here we've
got a camera here now I'd open this and
then I'm going to edit the video I
actually love editing anything more than
shooting the videos but I have to be in
the video to edit the video it's shut up
Justine open just open it
it just looks great it really looks
great it smells so good
you look you're beautiful your has
anybody told you you're beautiful lately
because if they have it I want to be the
one to tell you I want to tell you that
you are the best that you could be
anything else on earth not that I need
the directions but I feel as though here
they are
I want my Apple sticker full speed ahead
they're black here you are do you want
to be my baby what do you mean what is
that is it is my toy baby come on here a
water heater are you drunk
hello it's the new Mac Pro did you come
home I will pull this Solari
it's not a water heater my water heater
for the water here God is it beautiful
oh I've got a great idea let's make our
computer that looks like a water heater
do you how do I wash this thing maybe I
pull this pin
I think that's a problem I think that I
am in love like I don't think that I
have felt a love that I feel for Apple
products in my life is not a problem
Maddy what do you think of it do you
think this looks like a water heater
honey does it look like a water heater
to you this is how we do okay let's go
honey one put you down now okay ready
little wake up little leg up there you
go you are free look at this looking
good
cool well we've got this set up how my
goodness one six Thunderbolt ports one
HDMI for USB that's not gonna cut it
that's not gonna cut it that's not gonna
cut it all the lights in here baby new
magic mouse which you have to charge
with a lightning cable this is the Magic
Mouse - mmm look at you I still don't
like the design of this because they put
the charging port in the bottom of it so
you can't actually use the mouse when
it's charging but it does charge a
really rapid pace so that's a plus
alright welcome to the desk where the
Mac Pro is gonna go all the ladies in
the club put your hands up bang yo
okay this is gonna be good it's the big
rat get out one out
be my friend let's be free wow she's
lighting up at your guys and lit its lit
finally rechargeable keyboards no more
batteries turnin on albumen oh fast all
right guys the setup is now complete for
the most part uh I hope you guys enjoyed
this video let me know your thoughts on
what 4k displays since you guys have
seen that are awesome out there because
I definitely do want to look into those
but fingers crossed that Apple will
maybe announce some new monitors or
something very soon they definitely are
due for some displays for now I'm gonna
go upgrade and download software is you
start editing all night I'll see you
later peace
Samiha work work work work work work see
me